una Sangrienta y larga batalla cuyos
resultado podría estarse definiendo
según los servicios de inteligencia
británicos Y el Ministerio de defensa de
Rusia la caída de bacmut Es una
posibilidad las tropas ucranianas
estarían atrincheradas en el oeste de la
ciudad y a punto de retirarse
las tropas de asalto de Wagner llevaron
a cabo operaciones militares de alta
intensidad para capturar barrios en la
parte occidental de la ciudad de bakmut
las unidades de las fuerzas
aerotransportadas que operan en los
flancos apoyan a los escuadrones de
asalto y bloquean los intentos de los
enemigos de entregar munición a la
ciudad
una pequeña ciudad de 70.000 habitantes
antes de la guerra en el este de Ucrania
se ha vuelto el objetivo principal de
las tropas rusas y el grupo paramilitar
Wagner le daría más fácil acceso a urbes
grandes de danés como kramators y
eslogansk los soldados ucranianos que
quedan en el frente confirman el asedio
ruso a las líneas de suministro
tenemos barro hasta las rodillas ningún
tanque o automóvil podría pasar no se
puede entregar comida está tan embarrado
cuando Nuestros hombres nos necesitan
llevamos todo a pie durante tres
kilómetros no hay otra manera
en paralelo la atención por una posible
confrontación aumenta pero a más de 9000
kilómetros de backmud en el mar Pacífico
ruso toda la flota del Pacífico ha sido
puesta en alerta y ha comenzado un
despliegue completo al más alto nivel de
preparación Rusia dice estar preparada
ante cualquier ataque marítimo una
respuesta a los recientes ejercicios
militares conjuntos de Estados Unidos
con países de Asia Pacífico como
filipinas y a la atención en el estrecho
de Taiwán